[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros y hoy en
5 minutos con nos acompaña el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez médico infectólogo
de la universidad nacional de colombia
vamos a hablar sobre las razones por las
cuales se suspendió el estudio de la
vacuna de la alianza oxford astrazéneca
que ya estaba en fase 3 doctor buenos
días y por qué sucedió esto hola como
estan muy buenos días pues es durante
las fases de estudio de la de las
vacunas la fase tal vez más importante
la fase 3 que la fácil donde se
establece la seguridad en ese momento
cada uno de los pacientes monitorizado
es estrictamente y se presenta un
reporte de un efecto adverso serio es
decir más allá de la fiebre del dolor en
el sitio de la postura se analizar para
poder determinar si es segura y en este
momento sucedió un evento adverso serio
y por eso se tuvo que parar los estudios
para analizar el caso que llevó a este
si es causal con la vacuna o es un
fenómeno independiente
doctor la suspensión de este ensayo es
temporal o podemos decir que podría
llegar a ser permanente y cuál sería el
paso a seguir por los investigadores
también esto podría traer demoras para
países como méxico o argentina que hacen
parte de las pruebas
estas estas pausas no son infrecuentes
en los estudios clínicos lo que pasa es
que ahora como humanidad estamos
entendiendo cómo es que se desarrolló
médicamente una una es un proceso
estricto largo metódico y más o menos es
un mes en donde un grupo independiente
de los investigadores unas personas
todos los científicos totalmente a
partes evalúan qué fue lo que pasó y
miran si es atribuible a la vacuna o fue
una coincidencia de que sucedió el
evento adverso y la persona entró en el
estudio esto trae casos retrasos al
menos es un mes de cuatro a seis semanas
de evaluación y pronunciamiento por este
grupo independiente y en todas las
partes del mundo
si no nos seguimos adelante con el
proceso de vacunación hasta que no se ha
aclarado este evento adverso bueno
mientras tanto para todas las vacunas
que están en estudio siguen los mismos
protocolos o por ejemplo le pregunto qué
pasa con la vacuna de rusia
eso es algo muy importante todas las
vacunas que están en el mercado están en
fase 3 es decir en este proceso donde se
va a ayudar no solamente la efectividad
sino la seguridad que se someten a las
autoridades regulatorias cuando hayan
culminado la fase 3 y ahí si se aprueban
para su uso masivo en la russa la vacuna
rusa está en la fase 12 de las
publicaciones que tenemos recientemente
sobre 73 individuos y estamos esperando
los resultados de la fase 3 todavía no
los tenemos no sabemos con qué diseño se
hace un lado no hay libre información
sobre eso pero deben cumplir todos el
mismo protocolo hay que recordar que
adelante hay más de 30 35 a cunas esta
es una de las 35 opciones que tenemos en
la humanidad doctor preocupa también que
por razones políticas algunas empresas o
gobiernos estén buscando producir muy
aceleradamente las vacunas es
fundamentada esta preocupación
es cierto que la mezcla de la política
con la ciencia no es una mezcla buena
porque esto no es una olimpiada de quien
llega primero a la vacuna ni esto es una
victoria si se tiene la vacuna de la
victoria debería ser para la humanidad
no para un gobierno es necesario la
mesura la sensatez y el método
científico
hace poco se reunieron todos los
laboratorios que están desarrollando
vacunas para hacer un compromiso que
solamente cuando terminen sus fases de
seguridad someterán independientemente
de cuál es el laboratorio a la
aprobación y que no siempre refiere a la
parte política con la parte científica
en este momento necesitamos sensatez
bueno ya para finalizar muy rápidamente
doctor son comunes estos imprevistos que
estamos viendo en la investigación de
vacunas
de vacunas de medicamentos de cualquier
ciencia es un camino tortuoso difícil
para poder llegar a una verdad que nos
ayuda a todos no es infrecuente que esto
suceda sucede en todos los escenarios
clínicos y ha sucedido en varias vacunas
pero hemos salido adelante y por eso
hemos tenemos a la disposición más de 30
40 vacunas para niños adultos y se ha
logrado con este proceso este es un
proceso acelerado pero este es un
proceso que va a llegar a feliz término
no hay que desesperarse desde es para
lanzarse va a haber vacuna y en pocos
meses pero evitamos una vacuna segura
con método científico y que nos sirva a
todos doctor gracias a ustedes por poner
su expertise al servicio de nuestros
televidentes y sigan con nosotros en
france 24
[Música]